SPEAKER: In 2002,
FBI and CIA agents
thought they had nabbed a
diabolical al-Qaeda mastermind.
♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Abu Zubaydah has never been
charged with a crime.
SPEAKER 2: He was imprisoned
in the secret CIA unit
called Strawberry Fields.
As in, forever.
SPEAKER 3:
Prior to 9/11, the CIA never
captured or detained anybody.
They weren't prepared.
People started looking for
who was best to interrogate,
and there weren't any.
SPEAKER:
Psychologist James Mitchell was
the only candidate considered.
I just took it for granted that
they knew what they were doing.
SPEAKER 2: CIA officers were
certain he was holding back,
because he wasn't telling them
what they wanted to hear.
Something more aggressive
had to be done.
The lawyer's philosophy is,
"Tell me what you wanna do,
boss, and I'll make it legal."
We asked him to draw
what was done to him.
SPEAKER 4: Abu Zubaydah
is put in isolation.
SPEAKER 5:
Everything that was happening
was Mitchell's experiment.
Nudity has been approved,
sleep deprivation
has been approved,
noise has been approved.
The same song
again and again and again.
SPEAKER 4: He spent 11 days
in a coffin-shaped box.
He was on the waterboard.
I mean, this is crazy.
SPEAKER 2: The best evidence
of what happened is the video.
SPEAKER 6: What was
the reason why you thought
that it was important
to have the tapes destroyed?
I needed to protect
the people who were there.
Destroying evidence
would inevitably lead
to accusations of a cover up.
It would make the CIA look bad.
SPEAKER: It was
an impossible story to tell,
so I sued the CIA
to get materials unredacted.
SPEAKER 4: We saw constant
manipulation by the CIA.
Misleading Bush,
misleading Obama.
JAMES MITCHELL:
If my boss tells me it's legal,
if the president approved it,
I'm not gonna get into
what some journalist
thinks about it.
In America,
we have this thing called
"innocent until proven guilty."
We were the leaders
of the effort against
cruel and unusual punishment.
After 9/11,
that's out the window.
SPEAKER 2: Do the ends
always justify the means?
Are we prepared
to abandon our principles
in order to defend them?